bonsoir à tous comme chaque semaine
france info et l'ina vous offre un
voyage dans le temps à travers les
archives de la télévision pour décrypter
l'actualité vous regardez l'inattendu et
vous êtes les bienvenus là monsieur
bonsoir je voudrais regarder la france
au fond des yeux
j'aimerais beaucoup que je m'apprête à
tricoter à votre place je la ramène un
peu moins mais si vous ne réussissez pas
c'est qu'il vous manque qu'une seule
chose que tout petit détail les valises
à paris de ce qui lui arrive à la baule
tariq al dit gérald une cornée lavaud
bonsoir à tous les deux vous êtes
journaliste à l'ina vous avez
décortiquer les grands titres de la
presse cette semaine
deux sujets ont plus particulièrement
retenu votre attention
alors vous tarik et la fashion week qui
s'est ouverte lundi à paris la fashion
week avec cette question posée par
vanity fair que mangent les mannequins
pendant la fashion week et j'ai envie de
dire que mangent les mannequins tout
court un vu le diktat de la maigreur de
la minceur en tout cas qui est encore
très courant dans le milieu dit
peut-être qui n'a rien de nouveau on va
le voir dans une archive de 1961 dans
une école de mannequinat
d'un côté la directrice de l'autre côté
une aspirante mannequin écouter regarder
les vignes faire l'analyse de ces
lunettes
vous savez très facile vous allez voir
elle est trop forte rendre le cm pour
vérifier pour la taille nous avons 75
cm c'est trop faut pour les hanches 98
c'est encore beaucoup trop pour la
poitrine ça l'est moins
on a tout même 89 le coup lui même est
empaqueté vous tout ça le coût peut
devenir plus non il est empaqueté parce
que trop d'états d'ici le bas du visage
et en date et ça se fait très bien
maigrir
je vous passe la coiffure le maquillage
rien n'était cette année j'espère quand
même qu'elle a réussi dans le
mannequinat alors vous géré a dit votre
attention s'est focalisée sur la
fermeture des bars à marseille et à aix
en provence c'est vrai qu'on en parle
beaucoup depuis hier et ce week-end et
la grogne des patrons d'établissements
notamment pourquoi oui un manifestation
recours devant la justice les bars les
gérants de bars et restaurants ne
décolère pas accès à marseille parce
qu'il faut dire un cas marseille est
bien les bars les cafés ont dû battre au
bistrot là bas sont vraiment une
institution ça m'a fait penser à cette
archive elle date de 1959 elle décrit
vraiment cet attachement au bar on
regarde
j'aime lyon se voir comment les
marseillais terminent leur soirée et
tout d'abord est-ce qu'il la termine
systématiquement ou café au maroc 90 %
oui quatre jours tout en été est-ce
qu'ils sont fidèles et marseillais à un
établissement particulier louis assis on
y retrouve les amis de côté on
s'aperçoit qu'à marseille on parle
volontiers surtout dans les bars ah oui
ma blessure ça c'est une habitude
des siècles contre certains et notamment
à continuer télé l'apéritif le plus
important dans les festivités du soir
c'est le pastis d'abord et puis celui du
midi les mais c'est la manière trop
précipitée alors la chanson prend
beaucoup plus de temps et nos amoureux
aussi beaucoup plus et bar de marseille
cher à pagnol c'est vrai qu'un petit
verre sur le vieux port en tout cas
c'est très sympa alors ça c'était pour
l'actualité des derniers jours mais
sinon que s'est il passé le 30 septembre
ces dernières années c'est le zapping de
l'ina ça s'est passé un 30 septembre
regardez hitler mussolini chamberlain et
monsieur daladier signé un accord qui
dépouillaient la tchécoslovaquie de la
région des sudètes ouvrant la voie à
l'annexion pure et simple par
l'allemagne
moins de six mois plus tard sur un verre
sera maintenant le nom d'une justice qui
n'est pas l'expression de la vengeance
mais d'une morale plus haut au dessus
des mecs du siècle il y a une justice
après 12 ans de route et 8 milliards de
kilomètres la sonde européenne s'est
posée comme elle a pu sur la comète
sourit un atterrissage réussi après 15
ans de polémiques et de bataille
juridique le minaret hausse de 25 mètres
de la deuxième mosquée de france se
profile dans le paysage lyonnais un
accident nucléaire de premier ordre
s'est produit aujourd'hui au japon une
fuite dans l'usiné expérimentale de
tokaimura a entraîné une hausse des
niveaux radioactifs jusqu'à quatre mille
fois supérieur à la normale au
championnat de france des chauffeurs
routiers qu'une épreuve féminine
réunissait cinq concurrentes venues d'un
peu toute la france madame comment êtes
vous devenu chauffeur de poids lourd que
j'aime vraiment beau rameau pour les
gros camions
[Musique]
ce soir et demain la nouvelle calédonie
va-t-elle se prononcer pour
l'indépendance la question sera posée
dimanche aux habitants de ce territoire
français du pacifique sud un référendum
crucial fruit d'un long processus
politique
alors comment en est on arrivé là pour
bien comprendre tarik nous remontons
presque un demi siècle en arrière à la
rencontre d'une figure de la lutte pour
l'indépendance
jean marie tjibaou et pour commencer
nathanaël on va regarder l'une de ses
premières apparitions télé c'était en
1975 une archive qui plante le décor
alors à l'époque la nouvelle calédonie
accueille de plus en plus de
métropolitains à tel point que les
kanaks la population indigène craint de
ne plus avoir de poids sur l'archipel
la question de l'indépendance en ce
temps aussi gagnent du terrain et qui
porte cette voie jean marie tjibaou
on écoute les kanak sont là ils seront
toujours là et il vous en mer de long
jusqu'à l'indépendance que vous soyez
content ou pas contents mais
pacifiquement
malheureusement tarik l'histoire montre
et bien que cette lutte pour
l'indépendance n'a pas tout le temps
était pacifique
non elle n'a pas été pacifique une année
en particulier 1988 un particulièrement
violente 1988 c'est l'année d'une
élection présidentielle et en nouvelle
calédonie d'élections régionales
les partisans de l'indépendance ne se
sentent pas écoutés et jean marie
tjibaou veut faire annuler un ces
élections il hausse le ton
en 88 on le regarde il y aura peut-être
encore dix ans les gens qui réagissent
risque la peau mais ils sont pas un fil
de fer barbelé
ils vont aussi risquer la mort des
autres risquer la mort des autres ça ce
sont les paroles qu'en est il des actes
ne se font pas attendre à deux jours
après cette prise de parole à convient
d'écouter jean marie tjibaou et son
parti le fln qu'à son parti un plus
exactement attaquent une gendarmerie
cette attaque fait quatre morts
ensuite 27 personnes sont prises en
otage il se réfugie tous le commando et
les victimes dans une grotte une grotte
sur l'île
véa voici comment les jt en ont parlé à
l'époque les 27 gendarmes sont toujours
retenus en otage le gouvernement a
expédié sur place des renforts de forces
de l'ordre voici la zone au nord de
l'île où les forces de l'ordre ont
consacré leurs efforts précisément près
de ses falaises
on y trouve de nombreuses grottes très
difficile d'accès qu'est ce que veut le
gouvernement combien de mots river qui
n'ont dix le nombre de mois où on doit
arrêter parce que nous on arrange
s'arrêtera pas à 5 6 mo le fln qui s
entend attend plutôt un geste du
gouvernement est notamment l'un vaut à
l'envoi d'un négociateur dans les jours
qui viennent là vous avez reconnu bien
sûr henri sannier et daniel bilalian au
début de cette sélection d'archivés donc
cette prise d'otage elle a duré six
jours
le gign a fini par donner l'assaut et le
bilan il est de deux militaires tués et
de 19 indépendantistes également les
échanges s'apaisent quelques jours après
cette tragédie tarik quelques jours
après parce que françois mitterrand est
réélu à la présidence de la république
il nomme michel rocard comme premier
ministre et c'est lui
michel rocard qui est en charge du
dossier de la nouvelle calédonie après
deux mois de travail ils invitent les
différentes parties à paris on retrouve
donc jean marie tjibaou autour de la
table et son ennemi politique le leader
jacques lafleur à paris et une signature
va tout changer la signature des accords
de matignon le 26 juin 1988 une
signature un désaccord non qui prévoit
un référendum sur l'autodétermination de
la nouvelle-calédonie exactement les
adversaires d'hier ont accepté de se
retrouver autour d'une même table et
cela se ressentait très nettement ce
matin lors de la cérémonie de signature
dont l'émotion n'était pas absente une
page nouvelle va pouvoir s'écrire non
par les armes mais par le dialogue par
la tolérance par le travail par la
volonté et je pense que natal est donné
même si pour les militants c'est un peu
du lait tête dans l'immédiat pense que
l'avenir seul à reconnaître que ces
accords ont constitué un pas important
même une petite pointe de déception dans
les modes une pointe de déception parce
que vous avez entendu un géraldine
nathanel on parle d'auto détermination
et non d'indépendance donc si on traduit
pas de possibilités dans l'état
calédonien néo-calédonien indépendant
d'ailleurs pour une frange des militants
et les plus extrémistes d'entre eux ce
n'est pas assez ce n'est pas assez et
d'ailleurs l'un d'eux un de ses
militants en mai 1989 a assassiné jean
marie tjibaou
d'ailleurs on va voir sur ces quelques
images de ces obsèques beaucoup de monde
beaucoup d'émotion on voit que c'était
une figure qui a porté ce combat
jean marie tjibaou qui qui laisse
aujourd'hui son nom à un symbole en
nouvelle calédonie le centre culturel
tjibaou dont la construction avait
justement été décidée dans les accords
de matignon pour promouvoir la culture
kanak
merci à vous tariq
[Musique]
c'était un des grands titres de
l'actualité ces derniers jours le congé
paternité est passé de 14 à 28 jours
c'est le fruit du travail d'une
commission pour les 1000 premiers jours
de la vie de l'enfant commission vous
étiez là vice-présidente bonjour
isabelle filliozat c'est une victoire
pour vous de donner plus de temps au
deuxième par an à l'arrivée justement
d'un enfant c'est surtout une victoire
pour les futurs enfants pour les mamans
et pour les papas pour tout le monde oui
c'est vraiment bienvenu alors géraldine
avec les archives de la télévision
reflet de notre société
vous avez pu voir comment la place du
père de famille a évolué et le moins que
l'on puisse dire c'est que nous les
papas on vient de loin allez papa oui
ils reviennent vraiment de loin parce
que pour l'arrivée de l'enfant jusqu'en
1946 le père n'avait absolument rien
1946 petite révolution tout petit 1 3
jours de congés exceptionnels
apparemment dans ces années là c'était
largement suffisant pour les papas car
dans les années 50 il ne réclame pas du
tout plus de temps pour s'occuper de
leurs enfants mais plutôt d'une petite
reconnaissance vous allez le voir pour
cette charge qui a l'air d'être
insurmontable
regardez cette archive heures nous dont
le lot et de souply en finance qu'en
juin les plans répondent pas
plein de morgue salle datant
et
nous qui inlassablement d'ozon des
biberons pendant des mois nous qui en
dépit du dur labeur quotidien entre
prononcer leur plus jeune âge et à toute
heure
l'éducation de nos enfants envers et
contre tout nous qui savons sacrifier
nos soirées pour nous dédier la culture
de l'enjeu intelligence où nous avons
supporté dans la joie le fracas de leurs
divertissements
nous l'avons enfin autre fait et ce jour
là gentiment ils nous ont offert un
petit cadeau une fille par exemple mais
combien d'entre nous ont pu le garder
bien peu sans doute oui nous n'avons pas
volé leurs frais c'est vrai
d'accord c'est une blague
ce sont les actualités françaises on en
raffole je peux pas m'empêcher d'en
mettre
mais ça montre qu'effectivement à cette
époque il avait filosa le rôle du père
dans la société n'est absolument pas de
s'occuper d'un nouveau né à cette époque
là ah oui c'est même pas c'est pas du
tout dans la culture c'est pas bébé
enfant égale une femme les femmes c'est
vraiment une question de femmes tout ce
qui concerne les enfants finalement et
le père se considère comme celui qui
apporte l'argent qui permet à tout ce
petit monde de vivre il j'ai il se sent
responsable mais il ne se voit pas deux
comme ayant une quelconque importance
même face aux tout-petits dire qu'un
homme à cette époque et quelquefois
encore aujourd'hui n'imagine même pas
que le tout petit bébé peut avoir besoin
de lui il n'imagine pas qu'il puisse y
avoir un lien déjà entre lui qui est un
homme avec une responsabilité
et puis ce tout petit qui dort beaucoup
et qui n'a pas l'air d'avoir tellement
d'interaction expliquer justement en
quoi la présence d'un papa pour
s'occuper de ce petit enfant c'est si
important ça change quoi ça change tout
à vrai dire ça change pour le petit
parce que c'est une chose d'être tenues
toujours par une même personne ou bien
déjà d'avoir deux formes de bras ça
nourrit votre intelligence parce que
déjà ça multiplie les sensations donc je
sens et puis le foetus en temps il
perçoit son papa à l'extérieur et donc
quand il entend le papa real une fois
qu'il est né il le reconnaît et c'est
pas la même chose que maman avec maman
il a aussi un lien donc déjà il y a deux
liens et puis un papa ne porte pas un
bébé exactement de la même manière
qu'une maman c'est déjà une interaction
qui nourrissent dans les années soixante
dix ans qu'on entend justement ces
premières femmes qui tire la sonnette
d'alarmé en disant il nous faut un peu
plus d'égalité parce que pour la
première fois en tout cas la télévision
qu'on est dans les années 70 juste après
mai 68 ce schéma où le père ramène
l'argent et je
figure d'autorité mais ne met pas les
mains dans les couches un clairement est
remise en cause
alors dans les années soixante dix la
femme elle travaille elle choisit si et
quand elle veut des enfants et demande
tous légitimement ça c'est moi qui le
dit plus d'égalité au sein de son couple
et ça commençait bien par le congé
paternité
écoutez cette femme que la femme soit
l'égal de l'homme dans le travail et sur
le plan de la carrière et de la
promotion il faut que l'homme soit
l'égal de la femme chez lui dans son
train dans son foyer pour les travaux
domestiques mais également pour
l'éducation des enfants et même des
jeunes enfants évidemment c'est une
femme allaite son enfant est tout à fait
normal sauf difficile d'imaginer autre
chose mais si elle n'allait pas son
enfant je ne vois pas pourquoi un homme
ne peut pas le soigner lui apporter
toute la tendresse et l'affection
souhaitable et même si elle la lette
j'allais vous dire c'est un nouvel
argument ça par conséquent que le congé
maternité ne serait plus un frein pour
une carrière il est réduit car aidé par
le père alors l'objectif n'est pas
forcément de réduire aussi de réduire le
congé maternité c'est fournir aux deux
parents davantage de temps pour tisser
des liens avec ce bébé
une chose qui est importante c'est que
les pères s'impliquent davantage s'ils
sont seuls à s'occuper du bébé
c'est à dire s'il y a le père la mère et
l'enfant le père va être présent et va
s'occuper de la mer mais il va moins se
sentir en charge directe du bébé il va
moins osée il va pas se sentir légitime
toujours et du coup il va prendre moins
confiance c'est pour ça que c'est
important que parfois le père soit seule
avec son enfant que le second conjoint
soit seule avec son enfant
pour ben pour oser et du cours
construire sa propre confiance dans la
relation
d'ailleurs les pères justement on
commence dans la télévision française à
les entendre dans les années 80 si un
stress quand même un bon quand on mieux
moi j'ai trois enfants c'est un stress
au début qu'on le bébé arrive c'est pas
évident c'est un stress aussi pour les
mamans mais on est voilà et c'est pour
ça que dans nos recommandations
on dit c'est important de prendre ce
congé et c'est pour ça que c'est utile
vraiment qu'il y ait une partie qu'ils
soient obligatoires parce que sinon
c'est vrai que ce comme c'est stressant
sa fiche la trouille on a peur peur et
puis on se sent pas trop compétents
qu'est ce que je vais faire là et puis
il ya tous les toutes les
représentations de la société mais
surtout nos propres pères ne se sont pas
occupés de nous donc si on est un homme
eh bien on à cette carence à l'intérieur
on a pas du tout de référence de un papa
qui s'occupe et du cou eh bien ça peut
même être vécu comme assez paniquant de
ce que d'ailleurs les bientôt rouler les
premiers papa qui assume s'occuper de
leurs enfants et qui veulent s'occuper
de leurs enfants
donc c'est dans les années 80 donc là
c'est vraiment ils apparaissent dans les
médias comme vraiment des fous il n'y a
pas d'autres n'y a pas d'autre mot il
demande à jouer leur rôle de père
pleinement de pouvoir avoir du temps
pour s'occuper de leur nouveau né
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle on
pourrait dire pourtant à l'époque donc
je le disais ils apparaissent vraiment
comme des fous écouter juste le ton de
cette archive qui présente ce phénomène
des nouveaux pères elle date de 1981
quels sont ils ces nouveaux pères en
voici un exemple rencontré par dominique
thouars un bébé vient de naître il a
huit jours il est fragile il faut le
manier avec précaution et c'est son père
pourtant qu'ils s'en occupent le diront
un peu des célibataires avant maintenant
faut s'organiser toute la journée toute
la nuit
et comme christine l'aneth j'ai décidé
enfin nous avons décidé plus tôt
je prendrai le quart de nuit c'est à
dire le nettoyage le biberon
vivant s'inquiète lever tout simplement
de façon à ce que la maman puisse se
reposer tranquille un petit peu pendant
quelques heures les tâches matérielles
et ils ont l'univers professionnel font
partie de la vie aussi bien des hommes
que des femmes
donc je ne vois pourquoi les enfants
systématiquement serait versée dans un
dans une autre réalité
oui c'est peut-être l'émancipation
féminine qui entraîne l'évolution des
pères mais ce que toutes les femmes vont
accepter que les hommes empiète sur
leurs prérogatives et leur vole un peu
de leurs enfants
en 1981 quand un père veut plus de temps
pour s'occuper de son nouveau né qui l'a
fait avec sa femme
on le soupçonne de bol et l'enfant de la
mer qu'est ce que vous en pensez de
cette arche yeux car à siviriez en 1981
c'est à la fois surréaliste et en même
temps ça répond aussi à une inquiétude
c'est vrai que culturellement la maman
c'est son enfant mais en réalité sur le
terrain
quand le père est là la femme se sent
non seulement épauler mais elle partage
on a vraiment le sentiment qui a quatre
et paul sur lequel ça repose et donc du
coup on peut se sentir encore plus
proche de son bébé et c'est vrai on fait
le bébé à deux et donc autant
l'accompagner à 2 et puis ce qui est
important c'est que lorsque le père est
là dans les premiers mois et surtout
quand il est vraiment très présent il va
tisser une relation avec l'enfant qui va
lui permettre de mieux comprendre les
signaux de l'enfant il va mieux
comprendre son développement et donc il
va souvent être moins sévère et donc
plus vraiment coopérer davantage dans
l'accompagnement de toute la famille et
la femme se sentira encore plus à sa
place c'est que des avantages d'un papa
qui s'impliquent pourtant on reste dans
cette émission je pouvais pas ne pas
vous montrer cet extrait donc c'est
l'émission qui s'appelait c'est à vous
avec allah ni bouchon beauchamp et
c'était une émission culte rames
modernes pour l'époque pourquoi parce
que les téléspectateurs interagissez
avec les invités à la suite du reportage
donc des coups de téléphone en direct
voici une question alors notez bien
comment annick beauchamp reformule cette
question pour les découvrir
je voudrais savoir si c'est pas un peu
dévalorisant pour un homme de s'occuper
de ses enfants de l'élan g
de ce cap et de quoi comme vous avez dû
dévalorisant je ne mentirai pas des
virils disant ça c'est une question
beaucoup d'hommes se pose je ne sais pas
vraiment si c'est aussi beaucoup
beaucoup de gens cela pose au fond
est-ce que c'est pas est-ce que c'est
pas un paravent derrière lequel on
s'abrite quand on se pose ce genre de
question dans d'autres cultures c'est
tout à fait banal alors puisque vous
aurez la réponse est excellente c'est un
paravent derrière lequel on se cache
parce qu effectivement comme vous le
disiez c'est stressant
ça fait peur comment je vais me
débrouiller avec ce tout petit est ce
que je vais être à la hauteur est ce que
je vais pas le cas c'est parce que otis
mythe que soi-disant l'enfant serait
très fragile et qu'il faudrait le manier
avec beaucoup de précaution alors oui
mais c'est paradoxal il faut attendre
2002 et le gouvernement jospin pour que
la france mette en place
enfin un congé paternité oui à 11 jours
consécutifs en plus de ces fameux trois
jours de 1946 à prendre dans les quatre
mois suivant la grossesse prise en
charge à 100% par la sécurité sociale
un moyen à l'époque d'impliquer les
pairs mais aussi de promouvoir ce dont
on parle et à une certaine égalité au
sein du couple en écoute lionel jospin
il marque la reconnaissance du rôle du
père
au cours de la petite enfance instaure
une parité parentale qui est un nouveau
progrès dans l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes qui vous le savez est au
coeur de la politique gouvernementale
alors jusqu'à présent seulement 67 % des
pères prennent ces quatorze jours à une
proportion qui a peu bougé depuis sa
mise en place
comment est-ce qu'on m'explique c'est
quoi le problème en fait ya de multiples
problèmes il y a le fait que souvent on
n'ose pas on n'ose pas le dire à son
patron on a l'impression que c'est pas
vraiment obligatoire et que finalement
quelques voix on se prend des petites
remarques de la part des collègues s'est
pas encore passé dans la culture et
c'est pour ça que c'était important que
là ce soit obligatoire parce que alors
on n'a pas le choix et ce n'est pas le
père qui serait risquerait parce que
malheureusement ça existe encore qui
risquerait d'être traités de femmes
lettres ou je ne sais quoi
non c'est le droit et il va falloir ça
pour qu'il y ait petit à petit un
changement de culture et que les pères
s'approprie complètement et décide que
oui c'est complètement leur place
pourtant à la base dans leurs rapports
des mille jours pour l'enfant s'était
pas 28 jours que vous préconisiez mais
plutôt neuf semaines
est-ce que là ya pas un écart qui est un
peu triste ou avant d'être triste je
vais attendre la suite parce que ce que
nous précise on sait que ça c'est là la
cuisine gouvernementale dirai comment
elles gisent organise les différentes
choses et est au travail encore le congé
parental est donc si le congé parental
permet aux pères aussi de partager à
égalité avec la mer l'accompagnement de
l'enfant
alors alors super en fait que ce soit un
congé qui s'appelle paternité ou bien
congé parental ce qui est important
c'est que pères et mères puissent être à
égalité auprès de l'enfant qu'ils
puissent former couple qu'ils puissent
faire comme une équipe et qu'ils
puissent vivre le bonheur que c'est
parce que sinon c'est lourd être tout
seul à la maison c'est lourd tout seul à
la maison c'est lui je vais vous dire
non j'allais vous remercier en fait pour
expliquer que ce congé
grâce au travail de votre commission
pour les 1000 premiers jours de de
l'enfant passe de 14 à 28 jours et qu'il
est donc partiellement obligatoires
isabelle filliozat merci beaucoup pour
vos explications
l'inattendu touche à sa fin comme chaque
semaine ce kit avec une pépite de la
télévision française on file en 1968 à
monde poésie offert par le chanteur et
acteur serge reggiani il récite du
baudelaire voici un extrait si
quelquefois sur les marches d'un palais
sur l'herbe verte l'info c'est la
solitude morne de votre chambre vous
vous réveillez l'ivresse
déjà diminuée ou disparus demandez au
vent à la bannière étoilée d'oise ou à
l'horloge tout ce qui arrive tout ce qui
fait mis à tous qui fuyait tout ce
qu'ils chantent à tout ce qui parle
demander quelle heure il est et le vent
de la vague l'oiseau horloge vous
répondront il est l'heure de s'enivrer
pour n'être pas les esclaves martyrisé
du temps on y vrai vous enivrez vous
sans trêve de vin de poésie d'amour ou
de vertu à votre liste
on se retrouve mercredi prochain 21h sur
le canal 27 et toute la semaine bien sûr
sur les réseaux sociaux de france info
et de lina émission préparée avec les
documentalistes
elles sont très importantes de l'ina
magali bertin madeleine hors va et
eléonore prévaut encore lieu merci à
elle bonne semaine
[Musique]